so we got the story from timcast.com
jeweler launches anti-woke ad asking
what is a woman
what is a woman this is a this is a
what's fascinating i don't think the
story is inherently newsworthy
but it is interesting that people are
starting to push back and just begin to
assert
that women exist or that women are adult
human females
the reason i find this story interesting
enough to elaborate on is that it's a
jeweler doing it and why is a jeweler
making an anti-woke ad well
jewelry there's a very traditional
gender
norm in the purchase and delivery
gifting of jewelry it is very often
typically a male will buy shiny rocks to
present to a female as they assign a in
an effort to woo said female then he's
like hold this for me because i don't
want to carry it around well i i do
think it's fascinating when you break it
down to its root it's like
you know we i'm gonna reference chicken
city when you watch when you watch the
rooster do the dance around the the hens
he like pulls out one wing and then
shuffles around him yeah he's trying to
tell the girl like look at me i'm hot
stuff
males in our society buy shiny rocks and
present those shiny rocks to women like
look at me look what i got you know i
can afford this for you
and it's courtship
if you get rid of gender roles you're
going to eliminate to a great degree
jewelry people are going to people are
doing tattoo rings instead they're
moving away from this so the i guess to
break it down
what we're gonna see is industry
dependent upon gender roles are going to
start becoming resistant and pushing
back because they want to exist much
like you mentioned in a previous segment
non-profits have to keep moving forward
with new groups to fight for
industries that rely like let's let's
talk about you know honeymoon escapes
where they're sp they have rooms
designed for a male and female
specifically i mean they're going to be
like what do we do in this new
environment well i think eventually
you're going to see companies just come
out and be like no no we oppose this
because they don't want to cease to
function i will admit i think everyone
loves gems i don't know no maybe it's
just me but i i think maybe it comes
from that
men hunted and if they had a ring on
their finger and they got it caught on a
branch it would rip their finger off so
they wanted as little uh encumbrance as
possible so they would store the gems
with the wife i don't know if that's
really the history of why the woman had
them and the man didn't but then you
look like ancient kings and pharaohs and
they were all adorned with gems and
jewels and things like that so they may
have a market with both i mean the age
of hunting is essentially hunting for
necessity has has dipped not that it's
over but we seem to be in a wall
they're going anti-woke that's that one
particular jeweler
i tend to agree with ian
because what's going to happen these
businesses are going to adjust
to the new normal and so like this is
particularly acute
in the black community our culture is so
matriarchal
women are at the head of the black
community i
i
somewhat reluctantly have to admit that
and so what jewelers are going to start
doing is they're going to create the
custom
of women
buying gold chains for their men
they're just going to adjust their
business model again it's no dif for me
i'm 54. i'm old my dad always drove a
cadillac i now watch sports events
and the cadillac commercials now all
feature black women mostly they used to
market it to black men that was cadillac
that was the joke that was the
stereotype black men drove cadillac's
cadillac has adjusted black women niles
is it working is the marketing working
i don't know i just know what i see
and i'm in i'm just when you watch car
commercials and there are black people
in it
they're catering towards the black woman
primarily one thing a lot of people uh
notice is that commercials will have
mixed race families very often have you
noticed this oh yeah well of course
there are um you know more
what's the right word same race
marriages or well no no no i mean i mean
um yes but i mean there the people who
complain about it tend to be more um
identitarian so they're like why are why
are so many commercials now pushing this
and i'm like oh slow down there buddy
they're not pushing it they're trying to
make money off everybody and my opinion
is that they'll end up making money off
nobody right so so the point of the
commercial is they're tr you mentioned
you know black women with cadillacs
i i think it's fine if you want to
market to whoever you want to market to
right i was watching tv and an a a
dating a dating app commercial came on
featuring interracial gay couples and i
said you know look i have no issue with
interracial gay couples like by all
means have have your life live your life
i'm just curious as to how much money
they spent and how much money they think
they'll make off of a market that is
probably small i'm not saying they
shouldn't do it they can do what they
want
but it's interesting that the left
position would be like it's good they're
doing this ad because of diversity
but are they advertising to a group of
people that don't actually want their
product or there just aren't that many
there's not that many people to buy the
product when you're trying to relate to
them
so in the instance of marketing
cadillacs to black women i'm wondering
if a culture exists
that has black women saying they want
this vehicle
so when they see a commercial they feel
represented by it or would they just be
like i don't want that car
well i wonder if they're seeing their
representation as you know you know an
interracial gay couple that might not be
who they're actually targeting they
might be who they're portraying in the
commercial but they might just be
targeting
the people who would just care about
that sort of identitarian thing
generally but i i understand however and
maybe it's just my assumption i would
imagine that you know a young white
woman might be like oh that's so nice
i'm going to use bumble because
i mean look you're you're saying here's
a product for you and the you is someone
that is not part of that demographic
so if the commercial said
you know our app is for everyone male
female lgbtq it didn't say that it just
said find love and it showed you know an
interracial gay couple and so i wonder
if these companies will wokify their
marketing to the point where
they regular people will not feel
represented by it so in the point of the
the interracial couples and commercials
me personally well i don't care because
i come from a family like that so i'm
kind of like yeah whatever but if you're
selling kellogg's they used to have
commercials where it'd be a black family
and they're they're giving this cereal
to their children or be a white family
now it's mixed and i wonder if white
families or black families see
themselves in those families or just
feel like that's not me i would think
psychologically if you have a successful
solvent company in your marketing you
would allocate 10 percent of your
marketing funds to off-market people
people that aren't part of your
demographic you probably do experimental
campaigns here and there but only if
you're already successful i can't
imagine a company that is just starting
up would try to market to people that
they didn't think they were going to try
and sell to
i had a question with you about gems
really quick colin
biologically is there any evidence that
men or women are more drawn to shiny
objects
you know i i don't know specifically in
humans but there's there are a lot of
uh species a lot of you know insects as
well that do these like gift giving they
call them nuptial gifts and it's kind of
funny because sometimes they're shiny
sometimes there's like a built-in bit of
nutrition to it but you also see like
this cheating behavior where some
some male fly will try to give this gift
that looks like it's containing all this
nutrition but it's actually hollow it's
sort of like the cubic zirconia version
of like an animal trying to give you
know to to dupe this uh this female into
like mating with them by giving them a
hollow
hollow gift it's usually men giving the
gift to the woman it's almost
exclusively the mail it's usually
because they're seeking a mate to have
to have a child with yeah they woo them
over
so i imagine the gem industry is
probably similar to that then yeah i
want to add a point to tim's deal or or
the conversation in terms of
america what these companies think
they're doing and perhaps are doing is
just like you talked about with the
democratic party and their immigration
policy they're playing a long game and
so
the the primary
uh values freedom
and individualism used to define america
that's what everybody wanted i want
freedom and i want to be individual do
what i want to do
they're trying to make
diversity and
inclusion the primary thing
and so they're appealing to people that
believe in inclusion and who define
their identity around how inclusive am i
oh i'm inclusive of trans folk trans
people i'm inclusive of everything and
so that's what they're marketing
it's almost like marketing patriotism
and like the nfl and sports have sold
themselves this is the most patriotic
thing you can do come to our game stand
for the national anthem blah blah blah
their inclusion now is like patriotism
and so these commercials are trying to
hit the theme of inclusion because they
think they have socially engineered
americans to believe there's nothing
more american than being inclusive and
tolerant and worshiping i i wonder if
there's a big ask element i like
inclusivity
i like diversity
i i don't like equity i think equity is
a lie in a manipulation but uh
inclusivity it's like you know if i'm
playing a game of dodgeball and i see a
kid who's out you know not hanging out
with anybody i'm the kind of person
who's like hey dude come over and hang
out with us or i'm at a skate park and i
see a kid who's by himself about you
want to come over and play game of skate
like we're all chilling and what's your
name try and include people and i like
building community i like diversity in
the truest sense i like diversity of
world view and opinion
and the original concept of diversity
was that someone who comes from a
different community will have a
different perspective than you not
always but sometimes and so you can
learn a lot from people that you don't
know don't don't assume
that other people can't teach you
something the problem with inclusivity
is too much of it is a bad thing in that
if you have i i was kind of an outsider
growing up and i thought you know if i
get popular i'm never gonna let someone
be an outsider and i'm gonna bring
everyone in and i tried that and it
became chaos and you know what also is a
chef i'm an amateur cook any chef or
whatever but if you add every ingredient
it's a mess you have to stop you have to
add specific ingredients you use
discretion when you're being inclusive
you have to you have and that is a hard
a hard thing for people to accept
because it does mean that people get
left out and that's that's a sad thing
but it may be stronger in the long run
the issue now is that they've
these three words diversity inclusivity
equity have all just been perverted well
for one equity is garbage you know
equality i like equity is some kind of
you know equality of outcome instead of
opportunity but inclusivity was supposed
to be about compassion now it's about
homogenization and diversity was
supposed to be about different
worldviews and now it's just about
homogenization so you're not getting any
of these things in in in this woke
religion and too much inclusivity like
you were saying earlier you get the
fringes that come in and then end up
disrupting the very group you're trying
to build yeah and if you look at what
people mean when they say like we're
creating an inclusive environment just
to turn this on its head it basically
means the opposite in many contexts like
when i was first you know when i was
still in academia and i wrote a paper uh
for the wall street journal called the
dangerous denial of sex and it was about
why sex is real and why it matters i was
told that i was not making the
environment at penn state inclusive and
that therefore means
i needed to go
because i was making i wasn't making an
inclusive environment so i needed to be
excluded in order to make an environment
inclusive so it can be it can mean just
the opposite thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm now don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you